[Music]
we're gonna talk today about building
blocks around digital and IOT for
manufacturing it's a topic that is super
near and dear to our heart as Hitachi we
are a manufacturer that's what we do
it's in our core DNA we also have
consulting companies and technology
companies and healthcare companies and a
bunch of other things but when it comes
down to it at our core for a hundred and
eight years since we were founded we've
been doing manufacturing we have a
hundred and forty five thousand
manufacturing employees across almost
200 factories that exist in 21 different
countries so when we talk about as we're
going through this today we talk about
the challenges that are facing
manufacturers we talk about the
challenges that are facing really all of
us that work in the industrial space
we're living it every day we're trying
to modernize our own plants we're trying
to modernize our own operations we're
trying to connect our supply chains in
different ways
we have these same challenges that you
guys the manufacturers in the room are
facing so hopefully we can kind of power
through it together in the conversation
and have some good discussion so we are
gonna do our very best to leave time at
the end for questions so if you guys
come up with questions there are
microphones around the room I've been
warned that my co-presenter the
wonderful mr. Rob Lively he's gonna come
up and talk technology for a bit goes a
little bit long so it's possible we may
not have time for questions but we're
gonna do our best so I just realized
read me I have not introduced myself my
name is Ellen Dowd I'm a senior vice
president with Hitachi I'm responsible
for our digital solution portfolio for
the social innovation business so you
saw the video that talks about our story
around social innovation but for all
intents and purposes we believe that by
changing business you change the world
and that's essentially what we're
talking about as we go through this so
let's talk about this crazy world it is
pretty insane right now there's only
really one way to describe it which is
massive change massive transformation
we're all going through it it's
everything from the fact that the world
is shrinking
we've got globalization pressures that
are happening we have generational
shifts we have all of these trends that
are happening and what that's causing is
a shift of power and a shift of sort of
dominance in the business market so if
you think about the Fortune 500 for the
first I don't know eight decades of the
fortune 500 existed that list was almost
entirely static the same companies were
on it year after year to the point where
if a company fell off of the list it was
news we talked about it over the course
of the last 15 years 52 percent more
than half of the fortune 500 has dropped
off the list that is a staggering number
and it's particularly scary to the
manufacturers because for the majority
of the 20th century
that's who dominated that list yeah
there were a few retailers some energy
companies some financial services
companies but for the most part it was
the manufacturers that were dominating
that list so we are seeing pressures as
manufacturers as industrial companies
coming from every direction that you can
imagine how we respond to that is gonna
dictate how we actually survive in this
new economy so you can't talk about
digital without the word disrupter
coming reasonably close in the same
sentence it follows pretty closely after
digital but I'm gonna argue that what we
talk about as disruptors aren't actually
disruptors anymore
we've moved well beyond the disruption
phase we're now officially to the point
where these are just the facts of our
business this is how we exist how we
survive how we're actually getting
through working with the competition
reaching our customers generational
shifts are they're pervasive
connectivity you're everything is
connected our devices are connected
we're doing computing at the edge we've
got 5g that's coming out is gonna be
widely adopted within the next three
years connectivity is at a rate that
we've never seen before and the maturing
technologies are becoming mainstream I a
machine learning blockchain these aren't
new concepts anymore they're mainstream
technologies so we need to start
thinking about not so much about digital
disruptors and more about digital and
labor
how are we enabling our business okay so
here is the good news this is I think
where the opportunity really is so if
you look at the numbers so a couple
things I'm a consultant I've been a
consultant my entire life until the last
few years and as a consultant I really
like statistics so you guys are gonna
have to bear with me just a little bit
I'm gonna rattle a whole bunch off but
there's a point here and they're
actually pretty interesting so let's
start with the fact that Gartner did a
survey talked to 1,500 executives that
were out there and asked them this
question and before I give you the
answer to how many of them said this I'm
gonna again audience-participation bear
with me I'm going to ask this group of
people who in this room believes the
digital is a critical competitive
advantage or will be a critical
competitive advantage for your company
okay about the same so 81 percent of
those participants responded that they
believed this was a critical piece of
their agenda it was gonna be a
differentiator for them going forward
second question bear with me guys come
on you guys didn't seem really excited
about the hand raising but I'm almost
done I promise so second question how
many of you think you're seeing the
results that you should be seeing yet
from digital initiatives really small
number same thing happened there twenty
four percent said they were seeing the
results so how is it that everybody
believes it's a priority the executives
believe it's going to be a
differentiator
but nobody's seeing the results it's a
really really interesting thing sorry
guys it becomes more interesting when
you think about the why my knee-jerk
reaction when I hear that is oh well
they're just not investing enough
they're not putting enough money into
these programs they need to spend more
on digital then they'll see more results
turns out that's not the answer either
you look at what HBR is a Harvard
Business Review has actually figured out
if you look at digital leaders top 25%
of adopters in digital laggards the
bottom 25% of adopters they are spending
almost the same exact amount of money on
IT
as a percentage of revenue it's almost
exactly the same
it goes from three point two percent to
three point five percent that's the gap
it's tiny it's almost negligible but if
you look at the gap in terms of their
business performance it's amazing
eighty percent improvement on operating
income eighty and fifty seven percent
increase on profit line so those are
huge results without a lot of
incremental spend that's a huge
opportunity sorry guys I'm a little
parched
I think I'm drinking water out of a milk
carton is what it looks like so this
begs the question and this is really the
important thing how are they doing it
right if they're able to not spend that
much more money and yet achieve these
fantastic results what are they doing
differently than the rest of us what are
they doing differently than their
competitors so this is what I think
we're gonna spend the rest of the time
talking about setting the stage with
statistics and what the industry is
doing and all the pressures that we're
having is interesting but I think we all
are interested in understanding how do
we achieve these results how do we
approach these problems in different
ways tackle them in different ways so
that we can start seeing some of those
massive benefits that are available to
us if we do things a little bit
differently so let's talk about what we
think are the top four things that you
should be thinking about doing
differently you should be thinking about
changing your mindset so the first thing
is and it sounds really simple but it's
actually probably the hardest part of
all of this envision the actual business
change that you're trying to accomplish
what do you want to be when you grow up
as a company what do you want to be in
your industry how are you going to
change the way that you're doing
business so this could be anything from
moving from being a product company to a
services company changing the way you
think about R&D maybe it's not product
R&D anymore maybe you're looking at
innovation how to build true innovation
programs inside of your company how do
you actually change the way that you're
thinking about your business so that you
can design technology to help you
achieve that change
okay so this is everybody's favorite
slide I'm the only one that likes it but
bear with me a little bit so I also have
to apologize I have managed to develop
something in my foot that might be
plantar fasciitis so I may sit up and
down a little bit throughout this if my
foot starts killing me so bear with me a
little bit here but we're gonna talk
about it looks like most of the people
in this room are IT professionals I've
already asked that question how do you
actually then respond to this right so I
focused a lot on the business challenges
what the business leaders need to be
thinking about but as IT leaders we have
an enormous role to play in all of this
we have to modernize the way we think
about IT the way we think about
partnering with our business partners so
everybody is very familiar with this
concept on the Left anyone who's been an
IT for any period of time understands
the traditional flow of projects how do
you run an IT project whether it's a
waterfall project or an agile project
just sort of immaterial in this
conversation it still starts with a
solution idea you have a project you get
leadership approval to go do that
project you probably do a
proof-of-concept let's prove the
technology make sure it works let's roll
out of point solution even an IOT point
solution that could reap real benefits
once we put it into production you can
get benefits this way you can get
outcomes from those projects but what
you can't get is transformation well you
can't get is real business change so
you've got to think about how to widen
the aperture let more ideas through the
process get more connected programs and
projects rolling forget leadership
approval get stakeholder consensus
understand all the people that touch
your process whether it's your suppliers
and your customers and your
manufacturers and the people working on
the shop floor get them involved in
designing what this new business model
looks like and what the technology looks
like and do proofs of value we don't
need to prove the technology anybody's
doing pocs at this point to prove the
technology is missing the point
technology works I promise what we need
to see is does it actually solve the
business problem that you're trying to
solve and you can't find that out in the
lab and you can't find that out with
just doing a data model
you have to put it in production in a
pilot environment do it quickly see your
results get them back and then you're
able to have this truly connected value
chain where you're understanding that as
a manufacturer the decisions that I'm
making on the customer experience side
are influencing everything all the way
back to my supply chain and all of that
has to have a digital thread all of that
has to have digital connectivity that
brings all of that together so we need
to be thinking about how to modernize IT
and then finally actually not finally
sorry I have two more my third point
there's really nothing that consultants
like more than numbers except roadmaps
we really really really like roadmaps so
talking a little bit about what a road
map looks like for IOT for digital and
IOT it is a little bit different there
are different principles behind it but
it's the same general concept how you
prioritize and how you sequence your
initiatives probably has a greater
impact on your success or failure than
almost anything else and the reason is
what you're going to look to do is
manage these projects almost like a
stock portfolio you're looking to get
individual returns but it's actually
more important that you get the total
return so if you're looking at five
different points solutions at different
places within your factory one is an
asset management solution that sits on
one of your cutting machines if you're a
metals manufacturer another one is
automation that helps you make sure that
you've got better quality you've got
video analytics to measure work or
safety
those are great individual use cases
when you connect those together and
sequence them in the right way you're
actually incrementally learning from the
data that you're getting from the first
and you're taking those returns that
you're getting those cost savings you're
getting and you're reinvesting it in the
transformation so how you sequence these
roadmaps is absolutely critical because
the goal is not to get projects done the
goal is to realize value to get to the
point where you've got top-line growth
all those things at the top where we
talk about new channels new markets new
business models new ways of getting
money in the door and all those things
at the bottom
increased operational effectiveness
reduce costs all of those bottom line
savings so if you focus on the value
realization and sequence and prioritize
in the right way you will see the value
coming out of these programs and then
finally you gotta have an ecosystem
ecosystems are not new this is a you
know age-old concept we all exist in an
ecosystem but there are in my opinion
some differences some new things about a
digital ecosystem so I'm going to use
the example of Hitachi
and Google we are two huge companies
Hitachi is number 71 on the global 2000
list Google alphabet is number 65 right
these are massive companies their top
100 biggest companies in the world and
you know we're used to controlling our
own destiny this is what we've done for
the bulk of our career especially on the
tachi side as a manufacturer traditional
business what we're seeing is we can't
be the center of our own universe
anymore we can't expect all of our
partners and all of our customers to
orbit around us instead we've got to put
the customers at the center this is not
new but it is critically more important
than ever before customer centricity is
core to digital pettier customers at the
middle of that ecosystem enable that
ecosystem with technology whether it's
analytics or cloud or IT IOT all of
these components and figure out how you
then connect your entire ecosystem
together it's no longer just supplier
partner customer company that used to be
the ecosystem now it is how do you
interact with your governments with your
communities with all of the world around
you because all of that is required to
make yourself successful in digital so
we're really excited about our
partnership with Google but we also know
and I'm sure my Google colleagues would
agree with me even our two huge
companies can't do this alone we have to
have other partners in the mix other
building blocks all these things come
together to build these digital
solutions that help drive transformation
so with that
I am gonna turn it over to the guy who's
smarter than I am
who's gonna talk about the technical
building blocks how you bring these
things together unfortunately you're not
done with me yet I'll be coming back up
on the stage when Rob is done if he ever
finishes we'll see how that goes when
Rob is done and we're gonna talk about
case studies real-world examples of
stuff do you guys actually care about
what other companies are doing in this
space so I'll be back well talking about
thanks guys
[Applause]
hello everyone how are we doing this
afternoon okay I'm done so I'm really
excited to talk to you guys about how we
use building blocks and solutions within
IOT an industrial IOT in particular to
solve business problems for our clients
now something I think is important to
differentiate as we start this is
consumer IOT versus industrial IOT they
do something very important in common
and that is where we are trying to
acquire data bring it someplace that we
can do something interesting with it
however an industrial IOT we see
divergences in criteria that we need to
satisfy that don't exist within consumer
out a consumer IOT would be best
represented by something like the nest
thermostat that's on your wall it's
sending essentially the same data up to
the cloud all the time from every one of
those nest thermostats and it's using
the same kind of protocols and it's
doing this directly there is nothing
that mediates it it's directly connected
to the Internet and sharing information
on a cloud an industrial Internet if we
look at security as an example we don't
connect these devices directly to the
Internet even if they could would be
unwise because there's not a lot of
security on that existing operational
technology infrastructure so we mediate
it by putting gateways in them in the
middle and in that case
the security requirement becomes
elevated where we had secured in the
consumer side in the industrial side we
need Hardware roots of trust so that
these devices can attest to the security
of their operating system and the
firmware on the scalability side on
consumer IOT maybe to talk about
millions of devices connected up and
sending information all these nest
thermostats on the industrial side we
have to talk to thousands of devices and
thousands of different types of devices
so we need to be able to mediate that
conversation and have all sorts of
gateways that are doing different things
at different times with different
purposes so in order to manage that we
need to be able to do things that allow
for a variety of connectivity types and
a variety of different devices that we
need to talk to because we'll talk to
sensors that may provide temperature
information using analog signals or will
talk to you SCADA systems that have
their proprietary protocols or energy
sub meters that speak Modbus but a
particular dialect so we need to adapt
to that but there are also other things
that come up where they aren't a part of
consumer IOT we need to manage
performance so you have to be worried
about latency versus throughput in the
data that comes through I need to worry
about do I need guaranteed data delivery
or I'm okay with lost tolerance and it's
based on use cases so those kind of
capabilities don't necessarily arise
when we're talking about consumer IOT
applications but fundamentally the most
important thing is at the bottom it's
solution enable man with industrial IOT
we're trying to go and solve problems
for our customers so the industrial IOT
application needs to support the
development of flexible solutions and
modular deployment so that we can go and
build something interesting on top of it
so the challenge here though is Ellen
talked about an ecosystem of
contributors partners and we all live in
this ecosystem and need services and
components from the different partners
that play in this
but the ecosystem also needs to support
the easy participation of different
vendors in this environment because
plants and manufacturing environments
are not greenfield when we go to deploy
IOT we have certainly core IOT services
that are new are providing certain
fundamental capabilities to enable us to
bring on new devices on the edge and in
the fog but we also find that IOT
touches a wide range of the enterprise
architecture that provides some of these
fundamental capabilities you are talking
about on the prior slide all that
functional requirement become building
block capabilities that need to exist in
order for us to deploy solutions so if
I'm looking at this I can say sure
there's already security in place
mechanisms to provide secure
connectivity of devices onto the network
IOT needs this but when we go to a
deployment we need to see what already
exists there and if we need to amplify
or enhance that capability or if we need
to stand it up because it doesn't exist
so we need building blocks that can do
those different kinds of capabilities
for us and on the data side maybe the
client already has existing streaming
infrastructure we need to integrate with
that we need to get it to provide a
common interface that we are expecting
it to provide so that we can surface
data up and do something interesting
with it this is where a strategic
partner like Google comes into play
Google provides building blocks that
align to each of these functional
capabilities are important for
industrial IOT and what's more they
provide a variety of building blocks in
these different areas so that as the
need arises I can find the right tool
set the right building block to put in
place that enhances the existing
infrastructure that already exists in
that environment or I can stand up a
full-fledged environment full-fledged
capability when that capability doesn't
exist
where
go to deploy and Google also is
consistently innovating and creating new
solutions so they're building new
capabilities new solution building
blocks that I can leverage and do think
about new kinds of creativity new kinds
of solutions that didn't exist before
so this modular approach using building
blocks allows us to reduce the time it
takes to get to business value so there
was a great presentation by gentleman
Sam codes at box where you set a
platform and strap abstracts away a
messy problem so you can build on top of
it and that's what the building blocks
are doing they're creating a consistent
set of functionality in a consistent way
that data is provided and made available
through the infrastructure so that we
can focus on building the solutions that
take advantage of that again Google is
innovating and providing tools such as
anthos that they discussed the other day
in their thomas korean talked about
anthos being a single platform where you
need it because we want to reduce risk
and we want to reduce the strain on the
solution developers so they can develop
against a common platform and this is
reducing our friction to implementation
so when we talk about solutions though
we start talking about recipes and
recipes have ingredients in the solution
the specific code that runs on these
building blocks is an ingredient the way
we configure those building blocks is an
ingredient and these ingredients are
technically decoupled from those
specific building blocking limitations
and are reusable the building blocks if
we went with the recipe metaphor are
things like your oven your stove your
pots and pans the things that help you
to accomplish what you need to to make
the recipe work so let's take a very
specific example to make this a little
more concrete so if we're doing
predictive maintenance on weld robots in
the main in a automotive manufacturing
environment
I need to be able to handle a couple of
different things that need to deploy
across this entire infrastructure that
allows me to go do predictive
maintenance so what does that look like
first ingredient I need the right data
so I can define what data points need to
be except hold out of the environment
and that becomes one of the ingredients
my recipe that helps me to find what
sensors I need what kind of capabilities
need to be deployed within that gateway
device then I can start talking about
the modules that might need to exist in
that gateway they can talk to all of
these components that are providing me
data and what modules that might need to
be there to transform the data I can
talk about the AI machine learning
ingredient that needs to sit up in the
cloud that helps me to convert all of
this data along with data from the
maintenance systems into a predictive
maintenance model that I can then use to
evaluate whether or not something's
about to go wrong with that particular
machine so all of these ingredients then
can be specified within our solution
recipe and that's how we take advantage
of that building block infrastructure so
you're layering these things and
abstracting the baseline infrastructure
that exists in sensors and equipment the
building blocks that take advantage of
acquiring that data and moving it around
and then the solutions that sit on top
of that and expect a common platform and
a common set of behaviors so that we can
take predictive maintenance solution
that we've already solved and move it
somewhere else even if the
infrastructure is different and the set
of components and building blocks that
we deploy there are different so I'm
going to dive one section deeper and
look at what this would look like on the
edge and give specific examples so on
the edge the building blocks are things
like a common runtime environment using
containers being able to use a common
message bus that allows different
containers and modules are running on
the edge
with one another in a consistent uniform
specified fashion it's the way we
connect back up to our control planes we
can specify how these edge devices are
managed through edge lifecycle
management capabilities what's the
recipe the recipe is the way I configure
one of these connector modules to talk
to the device it needs to speak to so I
have a connector module that's talking
to that temperature sensor so it needs
to know how to read analog signals off
of an rs-485 port convert that into data
that I can use or it's a Modbus module
that speaks to a sub-meter and I send
parameters to that modulus module that
say these are the registers you read and
that's what represents voltage or
current
so the ingredient is the configuration
of this module another ingredient would
be if I have that model I developed that
says when this device about fail I run
that in this analytic module in the
middle and that's converting these data
points into real information that's
useful on the floor in the factory and
can be connected up to other systems
like their maintenance system or an
inline system to notify them of problems
so this brings me back to Alan's slide
and this is important because if you
take a look at that first piece it says
we're going to tackle bite-sized chunks
if you modular eyes this proach you can
identify what components you need within
your infrastructure to enable you to go
solve that particular business problem
and those are the chunks you bite off in
your solution recipe you have the
ingredients you know the code you know
the configurations that need to be there
that solve that particular business
problem but that's all you're chewing at
that point time so you're associating
development costs and infrastructure
costs directly with the business value
that you're creating it also helps you
to identify the value of some of the
bigger pieces within the infrastructure
all of these investments in data
warehousing those are big things that
costs a lot of money and take a lot of
time to setup so being able to say that
I have a whole portfolio of different
use cases I'm going to go support
and being able to associate that back to
that investment in the data warehouse
helps you to justify that as a larger
scale deployment and finally we're
focusing on the business need this is
all focused on the solutions this is all
focused on the things that we're trying
to generate in terms of value for our
clients and not on the specific
technology that's underneath it on one
of the previous slides
I said industrial IOT is the operating
system for solutions if I'm running and
working in Excel I don't necessarily
care if it's running on a Mac or if it's
running on Windows machine its Excel
that I'm interested in it'll work that
I'm able to do inside of it industrial
IOT infrastructure needs to provide the
right level of capabilities and then
disappear into the background so that we
can allow solutions to go give the
benefit to the client that they need so
this is how we deliver our solutions in
IOT using building blocks and solutions
so I'm gonna invite Ellen back up on the
stage and we're going to talk about some
case studies and show you where we've
done this type of engagement
in the IOT era digital disruption and
born-digital competitors transcend
business and society catalysts of
unrelenting change Hitachi and Google
cloud have joined forces to accelerate
your digital transformation journey
proven innovative solutions business
outcomes at scale on a secure platform
game-changing business strategies with
agility to ignite growth success starts
with collaborative creation and
commitment to a data first culture made
lob stocks mission is to drive
productivity profitability and
sustainability for the red meat industry
across Australia Hitachi solves business
challenges with digital IOT solutions
built on Google Cloud through this
strategic global alliance organizations
are taking businesses to the next level
with data insights to drive decision
makers the k2 data now is all about
objectivity and M Li invests in sensors
technologies that allows us to collect
more and more information the value that
we've got from working with Natasha
she's been incredible
we managed not only on-farm data but how
we make best use of it every transaction
that that animal goes through we need to
be able to map and track we're now
setting up weather stations where we can
measure not only the rain we're
measuring the temperature the wind we
are now starting to measure the soil
temperature so when you understand when
the best growth is for us it's very
important that we get all that livestock
data and together to be able to make
good decisions on where we're heading
together Hitachi and Google cloud are
helping meat and livestock Australia to
navigate this IOT journey
real-time data is collected from
disparate sensors systems and aerial
imagery and a massive data repository
synthesized and hosted on Google cloud
drives accelerated decision-making
operational efficiency
a dashboard view provides transparency
across the supply chain to improve
decision-making Google Cloud compute and
storage capabilities deliver reliability
and scalability the future is pretty
exciting the technology we're saying
today is only the start of it yeah we're
gonna see a lot bigger and better ideas
coming forward in the next few years
[Music]
all right so we're gonna talk about this
for just a couple of minutes and then
move on to a few more case studies I
know this isn't technically
manufacturing you could make the
argument that we're manufacturing meat
but I don't like to think of it that way
I'm a vegetarian so instead we're just
gonna look at this from a pure social
innovation story I love this case study
specifically because it brings that
concept of why you need an ecosystem to
life so meat and livestock Australia is
a public-private partnership with the
meat producing companies in Australia
and the farmers who are actually
responsible for taking care of these
cows so it is bringing together their
own ecosystem with our ecosystem so you
know Hitachi came in and did the systems
integration provided some of the sensors
some of them we got third-party we had
to partner with another company to
create the drones to be able to go out
and take aerial photos of the cattle and
the livestock we were able to bring
together that with the power of Google
to create a really compelling solution
that required about 17 different
entities from the customer side as well
as the service provider side to be
successful so it's a really great story
that has been able to show true
improvement for this industry in
Australia so I really like I really like
telling this story yeah Romania
factually very healthy live animals yes
that's right may in fact I tried it when
I watched that video I try to imagine
that we're just taking the cows to a
different pasture so that's that's where
my head goes all right so and I'm gonna
let Rob talk about this one in detail
but I will say one of the things that I
think is super interesting about this
customer and Rob's gonna go into some of
the details around what we're actually
doing for them but they're a global 1000
automotive manufacturing company that
knows auto manufacturing is probably not
their future they look to the future and
they know that they need to be a
mobility company they need to be
thinking about how are we going to move
people around how are people going to go
from point A to point B it may not be in
a car that they own in the future so how
do we build towards that but they also
know
that as volumes go down as fewer people
are buying cars as they're producing
fewer cars they also have to optimize
their manufacturing operations in the
mean time to be able to squeeze as much
operating efficiency as they possibly
can in order to be able to stay
competitive in the market so when we
first went to work with this particular
manufacturer they had identified 11
different use cases that they wanted to
tackle within their industrial IOT
infrastructure the challenge was that
they ranged from predictive maintenance
and predictive quality all the way
through to energy management and worker
safety and as we dissected the
requirements of these different use
cases what we identified is that these
were asking very different kinds of
functionality to exist within that
industrial IOT infrastructure in some
places we needed to process video
imaging real-time right at the edge in
other times we needed to be able to do
very low latency transfer of information
all the way from the manufacturing floor
through to the cloud combine it with
other data and send responses back so
that they can make decisions in
real-time or near real-time about the
way in which they operated the plant so
these building blocks became really
critical to be able to say this is how
we're going to go and put components in
place that support this and then the
modularity of the solutions allowed us
to define what kind of ingredients you
know code and and configuration needed
to exist at different points within that
infrastructure and so we were able to
take the same fundamental platform and
ask it to do very very different things
and still get the same responsiveness
and kroll control out of it that we need
all right and again I'm gonna let Rob
talk about some of the details here but
this customer I think is particularly
interesting because there is probably
nothing more old-school traditional when
it comes to manufacturing as steel
manufacturing steel manufacturing is one
of the first literally one of the first
manufacturing operations that ever
existed anywhere in the world and it
hasn't really modernized all that much
over that time so we're working with the
u.s. steel manufacturer who
who is looking at solving not they're
actually not envisioning this grand new
world of the future they have massive
operational challenges that they need to
address and they believe that by looking
at IOT by looking at better usage of
their data they can drive real results
so they had any number of problems
around and experienced unplanned
downtime of their part of their
manufacturing line a bunch of stuff was
done manually and therefore not
optimized
they had mislabeled products coming off
the line they had any number of
challenges there so we went in and
helped them again prioritize those use
cases and decide what to go after and
the challenge here again was that when
we looked at these use cases the
problems that they were finding that it
required a vast array of different kinds
of sensors and different kind of
capabilities that we literally developed
with partners that didn't exist before
so we were able to for example one of
the one of the instances was looking at
the tension on a steel line and whether
or not there was potential of that steel
line could break so he actually worked
with the sensor manufacturers to design
something specifically for that use case
and then it starts fitting off some of
this interesting data we needed to be
able to easily rapidly deploy
connectivity components out there that
would take advantage of that new
information standardize it bring it into
the infrastructure so that we could do
something with it and solve the business
case the other thing was that in one
particular instance the client felt as
though they understood what the problem
was with a particular aspect of cutting
some steel and as we started to put
things in place to observe what was
going on we identified that that
actually wasn't the case it was
something else about that process that
was causing the quality issues and we
were able to quickly throw in an
additional sensor additional piece of
information plug it into the same
infrastructure stream that data up and
immediately convert from solving one
aspect of that problem to a different
aspect to that problem so once again
those components and the the approach of
modularity helps us to respond adapt and
adapt very quickly and deliver business
value for the client
[Music]